hey guys it's Greg Alva here with the
lovely Madison Madison Cernik now you
can find her on Instagram she's a friend
of mine I met maiden I made a friend
okay yeah we do bad Brendon in acting
class
she's a wonderful actress she's also a
lovely singer and she's a she's a model
as well from my understanding I do not
all she does do mom ain't nothing you
should go to her Instagram house we do
bikini modeling well we do a bikini
model I get excited go to Instagram to
get excited and look at her photos and
like them so I thought okay she's here
she's here so let's do some videos
together
it's got sent to me yes it's called when
drivers go full [ __ ] I'm very
interested I meet lots of others in Los
Angeles
yeah right gosh they're the worst now
they make me so mad they're the worst
like no one knows how to drive in LA
it's the most annoying feeling but to be
honest it's sort of fun because then you
get my conch at them and the candy no
you can make it a game you feel
economy's wrong if you're like [ __ ] you
uh yeah I killed a stranger today [ __ ]
you
a warning graphic
I love that Oh dad like health care do
you idiot loss ambulance gets Instant
Karma I can already tell this will be
good
boxing ambulance would do that tell me
there's pick people up
oh let's do that yeah don't let me down
whoa why just happen to be recording
that yeah I know on this open read bro
[Music]
Wow and please nothing whoa himself
giving them all the evidence they need
to arrest him look quite funny
hey the crashing of logic are you will
the hidden run in progress shot by the
driver himself 144 New Smyrna Beach
Florida on Monday for nearly four
minutes the driver identified by police
is 18 year old Robert Kelly documents
and Robert oh no music plays what a
scene moving in and out of traffic and
racing through intersection the speed
police say were in existing live look
again music for the joy of the times
whenever he crashes into the back of
this Toyota sedan moments later police
say Kelly calls it the second crash
involving three other cars injuring a
total of three in most collision or
nevermind that's how much I know dad we
were in a mindless video after he
reportedly posted it to youtube Tuesday
from a shelf there wouldn't be any
driving like an idiot use my cat got
hurt and cry Madison going to Burger
King
yep
I mean really happy this just made to
come on you sitting a group of the cat
look so happy
Wow this one I can barely see that one
Allah Allah
[Music]
have you ever done this oh my god with
your feet
yeah you yeah I try the foot you know I
I wasn't very good at it I lasted about
0.5 seconds but you drive with your
knees it's harder than I look
it really is that looks like fun oh I
thought you I thought some romance
rumble that was he's strong
[Music]
ha what is going on I don't know that's
really impressive
I know you can do that I've actually
always want to help people can push cars
popular you learn in neutral Enid a
fiddle on gas station man sets a gas
pump and his car on fire if you tried to
kill a spider
yeah but the big McCracken aggressive
deadly foxes count answer now with you
crazy you know there yeah hey oh yeah
whatever gravity man with this man's
moronic moved it was all caught on
surveillance welcome our she's our
spider America well this guy did and
seasoned Adams watch the whole thing go
down Tuesday morning while she was
working inside the mobil gas station at
Van Dyke and 10-mile and Federline
Susan Capcom hit the gas automatic
dangerous now on the centerline fire
department the man grabbed a nearby
extinguisher and put out the flames
before firefighters arrived later
admitting to what he did he spotted a
spider on his gas tank because he is
definitely afraid of the critters he
pulled out his lighter and decided what
I don't have to be a rocket scientist to
figure out what happened that that's
putting closer to the spider ugh let me
put my finger right next to you sighs
ooh good baby turns over oh no oh no no
no that was really really like
disturbing oh yeah that was fun
[Music]
I've done this before why are you I was
infected and I was scared
easy honey bun Judith Baalim I just
wanna know he moves like this that's
right offer with that I can write a
fight fight without why would house this
pop you can derive that more people
shows your horrible thing wow oh my god
oh I think there's I think it's his
ex-girlfriend on my car what'd he do he
did like what would it mean something
kind of fun to crash cars I guess I
would do it actually if I got the chance
I would be afraid to do it for some
reason to be ashamed of me yeah I get a
viral video on YouTube yet yeah I
understand why people do this stuff now
bismi me I was like where's the cause
I'm like I guess you can get money out
of doing stupid things
what are you learning about you hey
what's going on why did you get out I
had enough room you were speeding sir
what's right realm you were CD I was
speeding
no no this is not who you are you were
speeding I had in the room you were
speeding oh yeah he was not
like she's watching the in my [ __ ] you
come
[Music]
whoa what is happening that's
legitimately and violent oh my god
[Music]
really good idea Jacobite well you
wonder why some be filming them doing
I'm trying to question their accuracy
Wow does this channel I hear assault
people are idiots you gotta subscribe to
these guys know what you got a
subscriber nice guy man butter do you
have any like car accident stories I got
into a car accident once that wasn't my
fault and the lady convinced me that it
was I was backing out of the parking
spot and she was going backward okay
when in a one-way street okay that's an
la jolla
so essentially yeah when you're backing
up and you hit somebody that's going
through that's your fault
yeah but not when they're going the
wrong way wrong way no you have people
were calling horrible is it my fault
okay what do you guys think I went to
school like hysterically crying oh my
god like this wrong time thousands of
dollars yeah and my car was broken I was
once in a hit and run for the front he
hit the guy oh no wait that actually my
friend was driving we were backing up
and then he totally slammed into this
guy behind him and then I was like we
gotta get the [ __ ] out of it and then we
drove and he chased us on the streets
for like ten minutes and then we
eventually lost him
my friend is something really similar so
she hit a car and the lady thought that
she was gonna pull over so they could
exchange information this is [ __ ]
yeah little anything to do we can't
believe I didn't do that I don't know
why I did him like well here oh yeah
okay okay um I guess that's life I would
love to I would love to do like a good
be part of you know those guys who
seemed like they were just intentionally
crashing into cars and stuff yeah that
looks like a lot of fun it does and if
the other person's insurance covers it
and you don't have to pay yeah fun and
then we record and get a viral video on
YouTube maybe I wasn't hit your car next
video okay yeah that'll be really funny
you could hit my Toyota with your nice
Mercedes I mean a money on that that
would be bad yeah no it would be bad oh
my car so cute I made my car
what do you mean you're her I used to
have a Mercedes that was named Harvey's
like sabrina the teenage witches
boyfriend yeah yeah I love Harvey with
Harvey yeah
like a big brown car and for some reason
like Brown is my favorite color and I
and now I have a white car and I'm like
likes this car it's too girly like if it
can't have a weird enough name like what
am I gonna be in that word color I
really like taupe now you just sound
more intelligent than me cuz I don't
know what taupe is okay taupe is like a
mixture between like this and brown
we're going to reference your skin first
okay no it's okay right here yeah but I
tried to name my car Casper because I
felt like Casper the Friendly Ghost it's
white black interiors are scary but that
felt wrong so then I named it Wendy
Wendy and now sometimes I call my garden
I feel like it's a super nerdy name like
my girl Wendy
well actually I know an Asian girl named
one day she weird
now she's really cool we hang weird if
no I chose the name I presume I thought
it was a yeah I would love to pull a
prank on you with hitting you with my
car what would you do I would I would
drive I want to find you when you're
like driving to Mulholland Drive I like
I'll Drive and then I would steer you
off course we'd start rolling down the
hill and then I last did you know camera
are you okay anyone name would you get
anyone do I give you permission
all right guys thanks for tuning in if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe I like it thank you me Madison
Cernik
you could follow her on Instagram and
keep a lookout for her you know on your
local television box set or the
Internet's and other forms you have any
like singing videos online or anything
she's a great singer but I've heard some
success on your Instagram videos you
sing you have a very lovely voice thank
you yeah
sing a little bit for anyone sounded
great on this cat mics but you know okay
I'll say for you
um what do you want me to sing anything
anything I'm gonna sit like this and
watch you sing okay
but sing to them I'll sing it out when
the rain is blowing me you see and the
whole world is on your case I could
offer you a warm embrace to make you
feel my love I feel I love you fcm 50t
you